so listen the first question is always
an obvious one but always a very very
good one especially when you're having
an installment that comes about 11 years
after it's the prior installment so Joel
what made this the right film to take
Puss in Boots to the next level which
this movie absolutely does thank you the
um you know it's
crazy because it's been so long since
the last movie and and I think Dream
works rightfully so was very focused on
we're not going to just release SQL
until it's it's
the right story
um I think for us like in our early
conversations
this idea that
put some boots is on the last of his
Nine Lives
um it's so absurd like and it feels like
ripe for a fairy tale that cats get nine
lives and as we kept talking about it
we're like but underneath that it's
about him realizing he has one life
and as human beings we're all just
gifted with one life and like this could
be a really like absurd and poignant
story and it just felt like it's so
relevant to to
tell now about appreciating what we have
you know you talk about yeah that one
life and if you go wow this is really
existential and to use the words
existential for a DreamWorks animated
movie it is a pretty big deal so Mark
like when it came to the tone of the
film The more mature tone the
existential tone what kind of
conversations did you have with the
filmmakers with DreamWorks and with
universal to ensure that everyone was on
board for this
yeah and it was um it is and it gets
dark as we know it's it's dark for an
animated movie
um everyone seemed to naturally be on
board and there was definitely moments
where we would be putting sequences up
and we thought I don't know about this
one because that's our process as we
work on the script but then we work on
the sequences and we show them to our
Executives in the editorial suite and
you don't always know what they're going
to say but every time we put something
up and we would be nervous they would be
like yep yep it's great keep going yeah
it's great and so we were sort of
surprised as well that we were given
this license but I think it does come
back a little bit to what you were
saying at the start we weren't just
cashing in of course we want to make
something that we felt kind of pushed
the film to a New Direction kind of
broadened it a little bit and by making
it this kind of dark Journey this kind
of Soul Journey we I think we kind of
solved it yeah yeah I've seen the film
four times I I know where does this guy
get four times see one movie but Jen
well what I was really able to keep keep
processing and absorbing with each time
I sold a film was the blend in animation
Styles specifically the CG animation but
also there is definitely a 2d animation
element to this as well so a talk about
that the process of of of that hybrid
but also the the evolution of Animation
since the first Puss in Boots movie 11
years ago yeah like you know we always
talk about how it's been like over a
decade since that last person boots and
even seeing the Shrek world and Mark
you'd always talk about how like
um it within that time animation
technology has evolved so much so to use
this opportunity to reintroduce Shrek's
fairy tale world and even the style and
Aesthetics to give it a refreshing look
to reintroduce the character we found
felt was very necessary and then
um you know with with other amazing like
movies like spider-verse that push the
medium we felt that like the DreamWorks
team was inspired to take it up and step
our game up as well and especially with
our um with our fairy tale world that
we're telling we felt that um the um the
the storybook illustrative uh aesthetic
really lent itself to uh the story that
we're telling and then it's got to talk
about the animation
um philosophy behind that like we were
playing around with going between
um your traditional step 24 frames
honest sorry your traditional 24 frames
a second on ones to what we call step
like lower frame rate
um we played with that um to um kind of
reflect uh plus is larger than life
hyper reality and his superhero
lifestyle so we would go into those big
action Dynamic sequences says in those
stepped the step storytelling of
animation and then for your more subtle
performances we go back to the
traditional ones so again we Joel and I
we were always talking about right like
we we love so many things like anime and
all these other art forms that we're
passionate about but we don't want to
just throw them in just for the sake of
being cool there's always like a story
Point behind that an intention certainly
certainly so so hater when it comes to
the score
you know here's a film that regardless
of the fact that it's a sequel or a
later installment it's a big film it's a
bold film The the animation is is
extremely
inspired and imaginative of course you
have a much much bigger slate of
characters everything about about Puss
and Boots The Last Wish is Big so what
was your approach to approaching the
score I I think it's from
frankly from a very small instrument
[Laughter]
um I played
in the Shrek movies I played all the
guitar solos when Antonio Banderas
appeared so I had that familiarity
um Puss and Boots was already a friend
but then
General and Joel
a very creative people and in being like
that they were open for me to try
all sorts of things so to answer your
question I think at first it's a simple
thing it's a Melody every character
has its own Melody
and then I make sure that those Melodies
can live together they can hold hands I
try to make sure that each one of those
melodies they have very different sounds
so by the end of the movie when they are
all sharing the screen and all these
Melodies live together and if there's
different colors we get something like
what you guys are talking about in terms
of the texture of what one sees
I try to make sure that I just paid
tribute and respect and love for what
they've created with the story and
Visually too so for example for Wagner's
character the wolf starts very simple
generally
very simple just a whistle
like a lullaby
but that becomes so monstrous and so big
by the end of the movie that I was even
scared when I heard the orchestra
playing so
I think for me this is this is how you
you develop something
so varied so varied so so the worlds
were so different as with the generosity
and the artistic openness of all the
filmmakers you know so these people here
in the terminology you know that I use
basically they are very musical people
you know and and I could just give them
all the music that I have inside so yeah
that's how it went so the great thing
about a great villain is that the
villain doesn't think they're being a
bad person or a bad wolf uh they think
they're doing the right thing they
really believe that they are doing the
right thing and so how did you approach
voicing big bad wolf and and how much
experimentation and collaboration did
you do before you like okay we know we
know what we're going to do with this
now oh a lot we we we were just trying
things there I was I I made sure that
when I was going to record with Joel in
general
I was just I just wanted to be open to
whatever you know and the feeling that I
had there with them was like that we
were playing I tell my kids my kids are
here and there was we were talking about
that this morning's like do I still I
ask them do I still have do I still play
am I still like a guy who plays with my
does my brain work you know kids playing
mode which is a very important thing for
all of us I think but in this case I
just allowed myself just I didn't
prepare it at all I wasn't like thinking
at some point I even asked Joe like
should the voice be something different
like hi I'm the I'm the one you know
like
experimented we experienced we tried so
many things and and they were like I
don't think so
no but we were really trying all the
time but like you said the this is a
very special character because it's um
it's uh the wolf is when I was a kid I
was really scared of the wolf was like
was the most uh one of the biggest
villains of the fairy tales uh world is
a very scary character
but in this case
this is scary but it has a bigger layer
which is like he's also there
teach something
the idea of mortality it's like Joel
said this film is um
has a very very interesting concept you
know uh it's existential it's uh and it
works in a it's entertain it's it's
funny and it's great to watch and it's
like kids are laughing all the time but
the the existential part of it all it's
really amazing I think it the wolf
brings a lot of that because he's the
guy who's there not only to collect
because his last life but to go like
leave your life well dude you know on it
deserved it yeah I'm curious because you
have a lot of new characters in this
film so using big bevels as an example
and the collaboration and
experimentation uh what was that process
like that collaborative process like
with your with the newer members of the
cast using big bad wolf as an example
till you went like that's it that's it
that's the way to do it yeah like um I
think like like Wagner was saying we
when we were recording it's like I mean
we were like we felt like we were
torturing you because we were like but
you were playing so much but we're like
just trying just that first bar scene
where he meets puss and we're trying
every variation
um because it was so important to us to
find a character that wasn't Arch like
you came in and said like I don't want
him to just be like a like an arch
villain there's gotta be something to
him and
um I think like what you were just
saying of like the the unique thing in
this is he's perceived as a villain but
the wolf isn't wrong pusses and puss's
point of view is the thing that changes
and um and so really kind of and and I
think
um I remember we were kind of like wow
like I love your process Wagner because
he like like you know we're we're we
have our our recording booths where
we're you're standing behind um the
microphone but like you were like pacing
as we're like describing like why the
wolf feels this way about puss in that
opening and he's like this guy he
doesn't appreciate life that means he
doesn't respect death he doesn't respect
you and like Wagner is and Daniel does a
great Antonio Banderas impression great
um it's great and uh and I remember like
you were walking toward Daniel since he
was reading your counterpart and like
man the look you were staring at Daniel
I I remember yeah like because he gets
so into the character and you were you
were just communicating with me the
subtext but you just walked up to me and
you're like okay this is just how it is
I'm just I'm here to kill you right now
and and I was like he's acting right
okay
but yeah you're even energy like it's
amazing gotta hear your Antonio
impersonation
himself
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey good to meet you too there you go
thanks for the reading
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for being here at the Academy for this
very special conversation about Puss in
Boots The Last Wish spread the word
about the movie and have an amazing day
thank you everyone thanks everyone
thanks Scott and thank you Scott thank
you thank you all such a pleasure